President Trump and the European Union
appeared to be backing away from a trade
war mr. Trump and European European
Commissioner Commission President
jean-claude Juncker yesterday agreed to
work toward eliminating tariffs trade
barriers and subsidies between the two
economic Giants the EU said it could buy
more products from the US including
soybeans and liquefied natural gas they
also agreed to resolve the dispute over
steel and aluminum tariffs president
Trump says the two sides are starting on
new ground we met right here at the
White House to launch a new phase in the
relationship between the United States
and the European Union a phase of close
friendship of strong trade relations in
which both of us will win president
later tweeted a picture embracing
Younker riding the US and EU obviously
love each other that's quite the hug it
was embracing look at that was quite a
little embrace there it was a sharp
change in tone for mr. Trump who spent
weeks attacking the group what's your
biggest competitor the biggest foe
globally right now well I think we have
a lot of foes I think the European Union
is a foe what they do to us in trade
now you wouldn't think of the European
Union but they're a foe the European
Union is possibly as bad as China just
smaller okay it's terrible what they did
to us
they killed us on trade they kill us on
other things they make it impossible to
do business in Europe yet they come in
to they sell their Mercedes and their
BMWs to US president Trump had
threatened to impose new auto tariffs on
the EU but they are on hole for now
while the talks continue Ian Bremmer
Eurasia Group president and CBS News
senior global affairs contributor joins
us now what do we make of this deal how
big a deal is it and what is left on the
table to be discussed between the EU in
the US it's love for sale yeah wonderful
to go from foe to love more so quickly
yeah yeah but this is a ceasefire it's
not an end of a trade war what we really
should say is that there never was a
trade war there were a couple of initial
skirmishes back and forth we have not
taken our existing
tariffs are the new ones aluminum steel
off of the Europeans and we are
continuing our investigation into the
automotive tariffs we're just putting a
suspension on actually implementing them
so the pressure is still on but the tone
has obviously changed the Europeans have
now offered priam totally if they're
going to buy more American soybeans they
will at some point buy more LNG when
there's more US capacity let's actually
see if that gets implemented they've
said they're going to work towards
lowering tariffs obviously automotive
would be a big part of that now we have
to see if it actually moves reminds me
of what happened after the Singapore
meeting between Kim jong-un and Trump it
sounded great
there was a deal there wasn't anything
concrete in the deal we no longer talked
about fighting each other but in reality
US policy and North Korean policy hasn't
actually changed that much that's
exactly what we're seeing right here I
heard two takes one take from the
critics was this could have been what
the president got if he just started the
conversations in the first place not
gotten in there with the punitive
tariffs and the criticism the other take
was he has leverage now because he's
roughed him up a little bit he's got the
EU coming to him wanting what he wants
where do you come down on that I think
he does have leverage I think short term
he ends up probably getting a little
more from the Europeans than you would
have gotten if you were just being mr.
nice guy he did get capitulation like
that on trade with the Brazilians with
the Argentine's and with the South
Koreans using the same basic tactics but
the actual relationship between Trump
and these European leaders is enormous
ly damaged and long-term that erodes the
strength of these institutions and
architecture which will have an impact
let's be clear everything Trump has done
in policy over his first year and a half
has been made to try to get the American
economy to be juiced in the short term
he's more than happy to blow out the
budget doesn't care about long-term
deficits more than happy to say you know
let's get regulatory off our back so
small and medium businesses will do
better the only thing that looked like
it might have been a fly in that
appointment right was taking the hit on
trade and that didn't do so that was the
threat to the US economy those potential
tariffs let's talk about two threat to
US national security in Russia we saw
the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo take
it on the chin from senators including
Republican senators yesterday who blame
the administration for a massive
cleanup effort after the Helsinki summit
what's going on now what have we learned
about what Putin and Trump agreed to
well
we haven't learned anything about the
two plus our private conversation that
Trump had with Putin no one else was in
the room except the translator and I
don't know if we'll ever get the full
readout unless Putin at some point wants
to give it to us but what we do know is
that policy didn't change the Americans
didn't recognize creme me as a part of
Russia they haven't actually suspended
military exercises in the Baltic States
they're not removing this but trumpet
Trump coming out of the meeting didn't
do any of those things in fact I suspect
that sanctions from Congress against
Russia are likely to be increased
somewhat over the course of this year
which is one reason why that invitation
to the White House of Putin has been
suspended yeah everything and indicated
that he wasn't going to come well he
just had an answer being yeah he
indicated that he might not be coming
soon yeah it is very weird that Trump
still wants to have this extraordinarily
friendly relationship with Putin
compared to any other leader in the
world friend or foe and yet if you look
at actual American policy towards Russia
even after this extremely unusual
Helsinki summit
the reality is US policy towards Russia
is deeply broken and it's probably
unbalanced getting a little bit worse
there not much to see here on policy in
Bremer thank you so much